[Musica]
Buonasera a tutte e tutti Sono molto
contento di essere qui con voi oggi e
potervi raccontare qualcosa sulla teoria
per la quale Giorgio Carrisi è stato
insignito nel Premio Nobel meno di due
anni fa e ci tengo a sottolineare che
Giorgio Parisi non è solo un grande
scienziato ma è anche una persona dal
carattere eccezionale che è riuscita
negli anni a creare intorno a sé un
gruppo una scuola una vera e propria
comunità di persone che collaborano con
lui e che lo stimolano profondamente e
io personalmente sono con orgoglio a
parte di questo gruppo è da quasi 30
anni e quindi sono molto
contento onorato e orgogliosi questa
cosa Ma l'affetto per Giorgio è stato
veramente
espresso in maniera fantastica dagli
studenti del dipartimento di fisica
della Sapienza quando è stato annunciato
il premio Nobel e secondo queste
immagini raccontano molto della persona
Giorgio Parisi tanto quanto i suoi
lavori ci raccontano della genialità
della dell'aspetto scientifico del suo
lavoro ma veniamo al tema della giornata
e alla chiacchierata sui sistemi
complessi e per prima cosa dobbiamo
definire Che cos'è un sistema complesso
questa domanda posta ricorda uno dei
primi è congressi dove andare sul tema e
a tutti i partecipanti e quando leggevo
le risposte ci rendiamo conto che erano
tutte più o meno diverse ma tutte più o
meno corrette quindi la stessa
definizione di sistema complesso sembra
non facile allora per incominciare a
cercare di capire cosa sono realmente
quei sistemi complessi forse è il caso
di incominciare a citare Giorgio stesso
che spesso dice tutti i sistemi sono
semplici allo stesso modo ma ogni
sistema complesso è complesso a modo suo
oppure se vogliamo parafrasare la famosa
espressione Maurice different del premio
Nobel americano freelandersson potremmo
dire in qualche modo
che il tutto è più della somma delle
singole parti e vedete che in questo
concetto già interviene il fatto che le
parti del sistema complesso devono
interagire e la complessità del sistema
non è tanto nelle singole parti ma nel
modo in cui queste parti interagiscono e
danno luogo a un fenomeno collettivo e
interessante molto più ricco delle
singole parti
Ma se vogliamo andare un pochino più
nella definizione tecnica dobbiamo
cercare di darne una anche se sia una
meta definizione E potremmo dire che un
sistema complesso è un sistema che si
manifesta a noi in molti stati diversi
stati macroscopici osservabili ok e
facciamo degli esempi per cercare di
capire meglio questo concetto un
qualsiasi essere vivente è
fondamentalmente un sistema complesso se
voi prendete un cane ad esempio Lui
chiaramente ci si presenta in molti
stati diversi Corre salta riposa mangia
abbaia ok e In generale gli esseri
viventi Sono complessi a diversi livelli
perché a loro volta sono formati da
organi che sono complessi perché formati
da tessuti di interazione di quelle a
loro volta sono composti da
macromolecole Quindi vedete che la
complessità si viene festa a diversi
livelli e ad ogni livello un sistema
complesso può essere complesso in modo
diverso
e gli esempi di sistemi complessi ne
abbiamo moltissimi ad esempio il nostro
cervello è chiaramente un sistema
complesso ma anche le reti neurali con
le quali cerchiamo di modellizzarlo è un
sistema complesso e più In generale
possiamo dire che quasi tutte le reti di
interazione tra esseri viventi possono
essere complesse Pensate ad esempio ad
un sistema ecologico o a una rete
sociale o a un mercato finanziario o un
sistema economico sono tutti sistemi nei
quali è l'interazione tra gli individui
che genera il comportamento complesso e
spesso queste interazioni è anche in
competizione questo fa sì che il sistema
sia frustrato Cioè non Esiste una
configurazione in cui sono tutti
contenti e questa frustrazione questa
competizione fa sì che la dinamica del
sistema sia molto ricca e a volte può
avere anche delle fluttuazioni enormi
producendo degli eventi estremi che se
si producono su grande scala noi
chiamiamo eventi catastro 15 quindi
capite bene che studiare questi sistemi
non è solo un interesse della Scienza ma
è anche un interesse delle applicazioni
questi sistemi si manifestano a tutte le
scale possiamo andare dalla scala
planetaria pensate al sistema climatico
terrestre fino alla scala microscopica
in basso ho voluto rappresentare quei
sistemi magnetici che si chiamano vetri
di spin sui quali Giorgio Parisi ha
sviluppato 40 anni fa la sua teoria ve
ne parlerò più in dettaglio dopo
Tuttavia per andare un pochino più nel
concreto dobbiamo concentrarci sul mondo
inanimato perché le regole le leggi di
natura che reggono il mondo inanimato
sono molto più semplici di quelle che
reggono l'interazione tra gli esseri
viventi quindi passando al mondo
inanimato in realtà di esempi di sistemi
semplici ne abbiamo tantissimi se
prendete un pezzo di granito Quello vive
in un unico stato tutta la vita ma anche
altri sistemi che cambiano Stato Pensate
ad esempio all'acqua che può esistere
nello stato solido il ghiaccio lo stato
liquido e lo stato gassoso il vapore
acqueo semplicemente cambiando la
temperatura esterna ha comunque sono tre
stati che sono brevemente pochi Tuttavia
voglio prendere proprio l'esempio dei
solidi per mostrarvi la differenza tra
un sistema semplice un sistema complesso
allora un solido è una struttura in cui
gli atomi le molecole della sostanza Si
organizzano in una struttura
estremamente regolare tipo questa qua ok
E una volta che Voi studiate questo che
si chiama stato cristallino ordinamento
cristallino di un solido e lo imparate
fondamentalmente avete capito la
struttura di tutti i soliti di quella
categoria di quella natura perché
l'ordinamento cristallino è sempre lo
stesso quindi in qualche maniera Questo
è un sistema semplice ne studio uno e li
ho studiati li ho capiti tutti
immaginate per fare un parallelo con una
come dire un esperimento e potreste fare
in casa di voler mettere dentro una
scatola dei cubetti di legno il modo in
cui mettete i cubetti è più o meno unico
avete un solo ordinamento se li mettete
a posto una seconda una terza volta li
metterete a posto sempre nella stessa
configurazione perché il modo di mettere
i cubetti dentro una scatola è unico
sono sempre Provate a fare l'esperimento
invece con delle palline volete mettere
delle palline di legno dentro una
scatola ma chiaramente non vi mettete a
impilarle come si impilavano le palle di
cannone perché sarebbe inutilmente
complicato quello che fate buttate le
palline nella scatola la agitate forte
fino a che le palline si addensano e
ottenete uno stato del genere che noi
chiamiamo stato vetroso perché lo
chiamiamo stato vetroso perché
fondamentalmente è molto simile a quello
stato in cui si mettono le molecole che
formano i vetri delle finestre è solido
se voi chiudete la scatola dopo le avete
ben compattata Vi potete sedere sopra ma
l'ordinamento delle palline non è un
ordinamento regolare come quello del
cristallo sono Chiaramente in posizioni
apparentemente casuali e questa è
esattamente se andate a vedere i vetri
delle finestre la struttura delle
molecole che formano il vetro della
finestra si chiama uno stato amorfo Cioè
non hanno un ordinamento preciso Ok
allora Giusto per farvi capire con un
singolo esempio Quanto è potente la
teoria di Giorgio perizie voi prendete
una di queste configurazioni di palline
e vi Domandate ma sappiamo dire qualcosa
su come è fatta questa configurazione in
particolare Voi potreste misurare due
cose in modo molto semplice la forza tra
le palline Qui c'è una sola forza la
forza di contatto le palline che si
toccano si toccano da una certa forza e
poi potresti misurare lo spazio che
rimane tra le palline che non si stanno
toccando queste due quantità sono molto
facili da misurare Noi l'abbiamo fatto
nelle simulazioni numeriche e quelli
sono i dati colorati li abbiamo misurati
e la linea rossa è la previsione della
teoria di Parisi capite bene che questa
teoria Aries descrive perfettamente lo
stato vetroso quindi questo è quello nei
fisici chiamiamo capire un sistema Se io
riesco con dei conti a riprodurre
esattamente quello che fa il sistema
l'ho capito Allora la domanda è come fa
la teoria di Parisi a capire queste cose
con questo dettaglio l'idea che c'è
dietro è la seguente voi immaginate di
generare molte configurazioni vetrose
cioè buttate le palline dentro la
scatola due tre quattro volte e ogni
volta le palline hanno una
configurazione diversa d'accordo allora
l'idea è che dietro queste
configurazioni c'è un ordine ma noi non
lo state riuscendo a farò vedere se
Guardate una sola configurazione
Tuttavia se Guardate due configurazioni
e quelle due configurazioni condividono
un ordine nascosto forse riuscireste a
estrarre questo ordine nascosto Ah con
le palline è molto difficile farvelo
vedere e allora userò come esempio per
farvi vedere Come estrarre l'ordine
nascosto proprio il sistema dei vetri di
spine quelli che studiò Giorgio Parisi
negli anni 80 del secolo scorso e che
noi continuiamo a studiare perché
continua a essere un sistema molto
interessante Poi avete una struttura
diciamo avete tanti atomi ogni atomo ha
un momento magnetico che qui rappresenta
con una piccola calamita immaginate
tante piccole calamite e queste piccole
canate interagiscono perché
l'interazione è sempre fondamentale tra
primi vicini se sono collegate da Una
lieta continua vorrebbero avere lo
stesso allineamento se sono collegate da
nanetta tratteggiata vorrebbe avere
allineamenti opposti Ok Queste sono le
semplici regole del sistema lasciate che
il sistema trovi la configurazione che
lui ritiene ottimale e poi la guardate
in faccia Questo è molto piccolo e qui
Vi sto facendo vedere due configurazioni
di questo sistema però un po' più di
variabili Ok vedete che sono
apparentemente disordinate Ma ora voglio
vedere se riesco a imparare qualcosa da
queste due configurazioni che Nel gergo
chiamiamo repliche sono copie però le
chiamiamo repliche infatti la teoria di
Giorgio Peri si chiama anche teoria
delle repliche prendo queste due
configurazioni dello stesso sistema
apparentemente disordinate e le
sovrappongo e quello che ottengo è
questa cosa qua nella sovrapposizione
emergono delle isole rosse e blu che vi
stanno dicendo le due configurazioni
erano molto simili al limite identiche
Ma voi non vi rendetevate conto quindi
questa in qualche maniera è il modo più
chiaro per fare emergere l'ordine da una
configurazione apparentemente
disordinata e questo lo possiamo fare
grazie alla teoria che ha sviluppato
Giorgio Parisi che ci dice
fondamentalmente Come andare a cercare
questo ordine Questa teoria È
chiaramente una teoria di base che è
stata poi applicata in moltissimi campi
e negli ultimi 40 anni e Tra questi c'è
il campo del machine learning Allora
quello che vorrei fare ora è cercare di
convincervi che alcuni problemi che si
sviluppano in questo campo del machine
Learning possono effettivamente essere
trattati con la teoria di Parisi Quindi
quello che vorrei convincervi che anche
alcuni sistemi che si usano nel machine
Learning sono dei sistemi complessi e
concentriamoci per ora su questa
struttura matematica e si chiama rete
neurale artificiale che è una di quelle
alla base dei processi di Machine
learning in particolare tutti quegli
algoritmi che usate correntemente sugli
smartphone di riconoscimento vocale
riconoscimento di immagini o anche chat
GPT sono tutti basati su reti neurali
artificiali di questo tipo ovviamente
molto più grandi di questa qua questa
però è piccola giusto per motivi di
illustrativi Allora Come funziona una di
queste reti immaginiamo che vogliamo
usare una di queste reti per
classificare immagini vogliamo
classificare e riconoscere immagini di
cane da immagini di gatto quindi quello
che facciamo noi presentiamo un immagine
sul lato sinistro della rete quello che
si chiama l'input layer Quello verde ti
presentiamo l'immagine e in modo molto
simile quello che avviene nel nostro
cervello quando una immagine si
focalizza sulla nostra retina e dei
Segnali elettrici vengono mandati alla
corteccia visiva il primo layer quello
di input manda dei segnali tramite le
interazioni che sono le lineette al
primo layer nascosto di neuroni i quali
a loro volta tramite le lineette passano
i segnali al secondo layer nascosto e
così via fino ai neuroni Rossi in fondo
a destra quelli sono i neuroni di output
che si accendono se l'immagine
corrisponde a quella di un cane o a
quello di un gatto sembra molto semplice
ma per farla funzionare voi dovete
allenare questa rete a fare questo
questo Task questo compito e per farlo
dovete assegnare correttamente tutti i
valori dei parametri interni della rete
immaginate che avete un parametro per
ogni lineetta Questa è una rete piccola
le reti reali che si usano hanno milioni
o anche miliardi di parametri che devono
essere assegnati correttamente per
funzionare come devono allora
Quando andate ad allenare correttamente
la rete e ottenete la configurazione che
sta funzionando bene cioè riconosce
effettivamente immagini di cane immagini
di gatto se guardate in faccia la rete
guardate i parametri non vedete nessun
ordinamento apparente Eppure un
ordinamento nascosto c'è perché la rete
sta funzionando bene Sta svolgendo bene
il suo compito quindi questa è già una
prima similitudine Inoltre se voi
allenate una seconda rete da zero con
altre immagini ottenite una rete
sostanzialmente diversa tuttavia anche
quella che sembra disordinata sembra
diversa continua a svolgere bene il suo
compito Quindi in realtà un ordinamento
sottostante c'è quindi vedete Quante
similitudini stanno tra le reti neurali
artificiali che sono alla base del
machine Learning e un sistema complesso
assumono configurazioni apparentemente
disordinate apparentemente molto diverse
In pratica hanno un ordinamento
sottostante molto importante Questo è il
motivo per cui la teoria di Giorgio
Parisi Può essere usata per studiare
questi sistemi alcuni sistemi in
particolare ed è uno dei con cui
riusciamo a spiegare l'intelligenza
artificiale che è uno dei delle linee di
ricerca chiave in questo momento perché
che funziona ci rendiamo tutti conto ma
perché funziona è una domanda chiave Ok
Lasciatemi finire con un commento un
pochino più tecnico Uno potrebbe
domandarsi va bene Ma come fai ad
assegnare questo miliardo di parametri
affinché la cosa funzioni non sembra una
cosa semplice Sembra una cosa senza
speranza in realtà è a parole abbastanza
semplice poi nella pratica sono un sacco
di trucchi e nella pratica voi definite
una funzione che conta quanto la rete
sbaglia ok Quindi per ogni data 7 di
parametri Voi sapete calcolare quanto la
rete sbaglia E cosa fate per allenarla
minimizzate quella funzione se
minimizzate l'errore che fa la rete alla
fine la rete funziona perché non sbaglia
più ok Quindi in pratica allenare una
rete del genere con milioni o miliardi
di parametri vuol dire prendere una
funzione di milioni o miliardi di
variabili e trovarne il minimo
nessun problema è che questa funzione
non è proprio liscia è difficile
rappresentata perché vive uno spazio di
un milione di variabili quindi non è
facile però se proprio la volesse
rappresentare la dovreste rappresentare
con qualcosa del genere un paesaggio
molto corrugato in cui voi dovete
trovare il minimo capire bene che non è
un compito semplice allora in che cosa
ci viene incontro la teoria di Parisi di
nuovo di nuovo sfruttate le repliche
Invece di prendere solo una pallina che
cerca il minimo buttate diverse palline
ognuna finisce in un minimo diverso le
chiamate repliche e Incominciate a
vedere quanto sono simili Quanto sono
distanti dove sono andato a finire in
pratica vedo un metodo analitico molto
ben sviluppato per capire le
caratteristiche di questa funzione e
quindi poter predire che cosa faranno
gli algoritmi di Machine Learning quando
gli direte ottimizza questa funzione
complessa Quindi in pratica è oggi uno
degli strumenti più potenti che abbiamo
per cercare di capire come funzioneranno
gli algoritmi di Machine Learning quando
li metteremo alla prova su problemi
difficili e questo tutto se a una teoria
iniziata 40 anni fa studiando dei
sistemi magnetici disordinati che nella
pratica hanno avuto pochissime
applicazioni Ma quell'idea visto che era
un'idea geniale ha dato diciamo aperto
nuovi campi applicazioni in nuovi campi
dove invece sta risultando estremamente
utile questo grazie anche al fatto che
la comunità intorno a Giorgio Parisi qui
Vi elenco i più di 300 collaboratori che
ha avuto e una comunità ancora più ampia
ha continuato a lavorare a questo metodo
teoria delle repliche la teoria di
Giorgio Parisi con grande passione e
quindi io spero che questa chiacchierata
abbia potuto far conoscere soprattutto
alle nuove generazioni e abbia potuto un
pochino affascinare nuove generazioni
come fui affascinato io nel lontano 1994
Quando entrai intesi con Giorgio Parisi
e che siano le nuove generazioni a
continuare a sviluppare Questa teoria
per renderla sempre più efficiente più
robusta e che possa portare a nuovi
risultati
da Nobel e quindi con questo vi
ringrazio per la vostra attenzione
[Applauso]
[Musica]